hi there check out these videos on the
top each one kind of contains a
repeating action so on the left you see
someone doing jumping jacks in a fairly
regular pattern in the middle it gets a
bit more difficult because what you see
is a tennis ball bouncing and it bounces
faster and faster and faster as time
goes on on the right you see that there
is a short intro sequence before the
repeating action the person shoveling
the cement is displayed so the goal here
is to build an AI that can detect that a
repeating action is happening and if it
detects so that it can count how often
this repeating action is happening you
can already see the difficulties here is
not only the recognition itself but the
fact that the repeating actions can be
different and can breathe different
lengths and cannot always look the same
and so on so this paper uses these self
these temporal self similarity matrices
that you see at the bottom here to
achieve this and we're going to explore
how that's happening so the paper we'll
look at is called counting out time
class agnostic video repetition counting
in the wild by Deborah Deborah Dewey BD
Yosef ITAR Jonathan Thompson Pierre
sermonette and andrew zisserman of
google research and deep mind so as I
already said this paper detects
repeating actions and is able to count
them and on a high level what they do is
they encode the video using
convolutional networks then they build
these temporal self similarity matrices
between the frames in order to detect
the repetitions and they decode that
into the predictions using another
neural network this is all trained end
to end and they also make a new data set
for this task so that's the high level
if you want to find out how exactly
that's done I invite you to stick around
because we'll go into the paper if you
like content like this don't forget to
share it out leave
like and tell me what you think of the
paper in the comments I do read the
comments so yeah I'm very happy to read
what you all think about it okay so as
we already said they say we present an
approach for estimating the period with
which an action is repeated in a video
and that's actually understating what
the problem is here the problem is many
many folds as you can see on the right
here even if you don't get what this
self similarity matrix is yet the
outputs that you want are at the bottom
so what you want is first of all a per
frame periodicity prediction so that
means that for each frame you want to
know is there even a repeating action
happening or not in that particular
frame you can see here at the beginning
at the end of the video there is no
repeating action and then in the middle
there is a repeating action so that's
the first thing you want to know the
second thing is this per frame period
length prediction so for each frame that
is part of a repeating action you want
to know what is the period length of
that repeating action and that can
change throughout the video so you
needed per frame and once you have it
per frame you can actually count the
number of repetitions okay so those are
two problems already the third problem
that this paper solves is that there is
no adequate data set to train a model
like this it seems for example this
model right here this Q UV a data set I
believe has 100 data points and these
are mostly these are meant for testing
so you would build your system somewhere
and then you would test it on those 100
data points but they claim not even
those are you know large and diverse
enough for these systems to be evaluated
so they build we also collect a new
challenging data set called Celtx which
is 90 times larger than existing data
sets which captures the challenges of
repetition counting in real-world videos
and that actually consists of a train
and test split so
you can also train a system using it
let's dive into the architecture
I think this paper is a very very very
cool example of even though we're in
this deep learning paradigm where you
just throw neural networks at a problem
and it's a very cool example that you
can still achieve a lot by smartly
constructing this because we used to
achieve a lot by smartly constructing
features and so on in this case the the
goal is achieved by smartly constructing
the architecture of the neural network
itself to give you back a good
performance on the particular task right
here ok so if that tablet lets me
actually scroll around let's go to the
architecture so figure 2 shows the
architecture in more detail so we'll go
through it from the beginning to the end
actually let's go let's go to the end so
you know what is supposed to happen
so for each frame in this video what
we'll need is a period length and a
periodicity these are two so the bottom
is a binary variable and the top is a
it's actually a number but it is
predicted in kind of binned as a
classification task it doesn't really
matter we need two outputs that we can
compare with the labels right in this
case the videos are of length 64 so
there's 64 frames per video and for each
of those frames we want a period length
and for each of those frames we want a
periodicity binary prediction and that
as I said we compare with our labels and
then we can calculate a loss so this is
the loss the losses at the end comparing
these two labels and then everything
else is trained using back propagation
on that loss okay
so now with that in mind let's go to the
beginning so the video is taken and fed
through an encoder in order to produce
these per frame embeddings so we want an
embedding for each frame that means for
each of the 64 frames we want to obtain
one vector of length 512 that disk
that particular frame in terms that the
model can understand and we do that
using an encoder now the encoder it has
a bunch of parts to it it's not just a
blob as you see right here so the
encoder consists of three things first
of all there's this convolutional
feature extractor which is a resonant 50
architecture is simply a convolution and
you let the convolutional neural network
run on each frame independently this is
simply a feature extractor from images
like you know it from any other image
processing task but of course here we
have a video so it would be nice if the
it would be nice if the frames knew
something about the other frames right
especially if you think of something
like a jumping jack if you are in this
position right here it it doesn't tell
you everything about that video frame if
you consider the frame before it and
maybe the frame before it is this and
maybe the frame after it is that you can
clearly see that the hands or the arms
are in an upward motion so the next step
of the encoder tries to integrate that
temporal information into the embeddings
and that is achieved via a 3d
convolution so once once we process each
frame individually then we feed it into
one layer through a layer of 3d
convolution to add local temporal
information to the per frame features so
if you don't know what a 3d convolution
is of this I already drew so in a 2d
convolution what you want to do is you
want to have this filter right here
which is a 2d filter for each of the
channels and you slide it across the
image like this okay and you can have
multiple channels of the input image
right here and you can actually do this
multiple times which corresponds to
multiple output channels of the filters
but
actual convolution is happening in two
dimensions so the sliding is across the
width and the height of the image in
contrast to that if you have a 3d
convolution and you have the same input
stack of images and now this we have to
you have to pay attention here this
right this stack right here is the
individual channels of one image so of
one video frame this stack right here
that I'm drawing these are the video
frames stacked now each of these stacked
video frames can have multiple channels
resulting from its 2d convolution or
even just RGB so I can't really draw in
four dimensions but now we stack the
video frames and now our kernel our
filter will be also in the direction of
the video frame so I don't know if this
is really recognizable if I draw it like
this but as you can see the kernel is
not only 2d but 3d and now the sliding
so if we have actually more than that
the sliding is not only done into the
direction of height and width but also
into the direction of depth so that each
of the frames each of the video frames
right here can incorporate information
from its immediate neighbors in case of
a three by three by three filter or even
more neighbors but here we use it three
by three by three filter okay so that's
that's how we obtain these embeddings
right here and at the end there is a
dimension reduction like a max pooling
or something but ultimately what you'll
end up with is for each of the 64 video
frames you get one vector and that
vector mainly describes that particular
video frame like if you consider the
green one here but also contains
information from the video frame before
it and from the video frame after it
okay so that's sort of an and that's
that's the so the temporal convolution
is not to detect the periodic actions
because it's just one frame into the
future and into the past it is more like
what we said here in
to give you extra information of what's
happening in a particular frame because
especially for periodicity it's actually
important if the arms are going up or
down
cool so then comes the heart of the
architecture the heart of the
architecture is this temporal
self-similarity matrix now what does
this do this is relating the frames to
each other and important to note here
this is just a single channel image so
there is no other ones of these for the
entire video frame sequence you have one
64 by 64 matrix and all the signal has
to go through this matrix right
everything from here is only through
this matrix there's no residual
connections there's no skip connections
that's all that's your information
bottleneck and by having a bottleneck
like this these the authors here force
the model to basically do a good job at
making this temporal self-similarity
happen if it wants to achieve a low loss
and that's what I mean by you can
achieve a lot by having a smart
architecture this temporal
self-similarity matrix is actually not
learned this can be computed
deterministically from the embeddings
right here so what you do is you each
row here corresponds to one frame so you
take each frame that corresponds to a
row and you calculate simply the the
distance to or the similarity with each
of the other frames so this is as you
can see it's 64 by 64 so frame I here is
simply compared to each of the other
frames J and depending on whether that
embedding is very similar to the
embedding of frame J this number is
going to be high or low
now there's also a after that you do a
softmax across here such that this is
going to be like a distribution and not
just raw numbers but that's ultimately
not that important so what you can see
is that the diagonal is very prominent
and that makes sense because
technically the diagonal is always one
right if for example if you use the
inner product as a similarity the
diagonal should always be one but here
we have the softmax so it's not but
ultimately we can say that any frame
should be very similar to its is going
to be very similar to itself so that's
why but then you can see right here
there's a pattern emerging and that
pattern is these diagonal lines in this
direction as you can see and what what
does that mean they actually have a
larger version of this down here so what
does the diagonal pattern mean it means
that so here the diagonal that's okay
frame I is very similar to frame I cool
but the other lines what do they mean so
if I look at frame I right here it is
also very similar to this frame J now
this wouldn't be further you know frames
are similar but the line means that if I
have if I look 10 frames later I plus 10
that's very similar to J plus 10 and if
I now look at I plus 20 frame that's
very similar to J plus 20 so this is the
this is here why the the pattern is
emerging of a line because if I go ten
frames into the future it's similar to
the other one ten frames into the future
and so on and that means the line
indicates that this entire sequence
starting from I 20 frames into the
future is repeated starting from J
actually J is earlier here so but you
get the point and if I have a bunch of
these lines that means that this sub
sequence is repeated again and again and
again throughout the video so each of
these lines is basically one repetition
of the sequence from the middle here at
some other point in the video and that's
pretty fascinating and that's these
these self similarity matrices that's
what they're sort of showing now they
don't use the inner
product here as a self similarity metric
they actually use as you can see right
here they use the negative square
distance but the effect is the same so
negative square distance followed by a
row wise softmax
operation so you could say hi we are
basically done having the self
similarity matrix what we could do let's
let's say we could train it we don't
worry about how to train it we could
simply take each row right here and we
plot the intensity across that row and
that's maybe you know like something
like this and then there is the diagonal
is a bit higher okay we could just use a
heuristic to detect these bumps here
basically calculate the length count the
bumps and calculate the period length
right that that should be pretty easy
with like a simple heuristic but the
authors here they want more they want to
solve more problems so what are some of
the problems we already saw some of the
problems namely for example here is the
hammer throw
so the hammer throw starts out slow and
gets faster and faster and faster and
you can see this pretty clearly at the
lines right here namely if you go
through time so you start off here and
you go through time you can see that the
distance to the next line here is fairly
large but you go through time further
the distance gets shorter you go through
time further the distance gets even
shorter so these pattern of lines here
that's kind of converging towards that
it indicates that this repeating action
gets faster and faster and faster this
is nice to see her at the bouncy ball
example where you can see it starts out
pretty slow but it gets faster and
faster and here you if you if you have
this full thing right here that
basically means all the frames are self
similar to each other which basically
means if you stop the video right that's
if you have ten frames in a row the same
thing the ball is just lying on the
ground all of these frames will be self
similar so there's probably no bouncing
happening down here
you can see pretty well from the pattern
what happens and here in this mixing
concrete example that we saw at the
beginning you can see that at the
beginning at the end there is this intro
and outro sequence and only in the
middle is there a repeating action and
that's indicated by this line pattern is
only at the in the middle of the videos
only between here and here so it's it's
gonna be pretty difficult to just have a
heuristic that reads out these periodic
action periodicity and in a true deep
learning fashion the the authors here oh
sorry maybe you can't see that I've
shifted my recording window so maybe
sometimes something's out of frame and
you have to yell at me if I do that
please so I hope you you saw this that
you have the ever the speeding up here
and here we're visible in the pattern
and then here you have the beginning
sequence the end sequence that have no
repeating pattern and the repeating
pattern only merged in the middle so the
author's want to do this through of
course a deep learning Network they want
to read out the periodicity
not through a heuristic but using a deep
network you know respectable that's at
the times we live in so what do they do
first of all you have to see right here
everything that happens from here as I
understand it is per frame so they
simply take a row of this matrix right
here like this red line and that is
independently pulled through to the end
so there is no interaction happening
anymore between the individual frame
data the only interaction that happens
is a little bit here at the temporal
convolutions but the only real
interaction between the frames is
happening through the self similarity
matrix and again this is the information
bottleneck that the author's force the
information through everything happening
from here no that's actually not right
there is this convolution right here but
still this is the information
you have to go through so right here we
process this image using a convolution
so this is an image right and we can
process it using a convolutional neural
network so what we do is we have a 64 by
64 image in one channel we simply up
sample that not up sample but we expand
the channels to 32 channels as I said
it's pretty easy to think we can just go
to the end here
use a convenant to produce our final 512
by so 512 embeddings we have here again
64 by 64 that we then use to predict the
final result but the authors here do
something different they do transformer
layers in the middle but only per frame
so what does it mean so here you up
sample to 32 channels and then that
means that one of these blocks right
here one of these blocks corresponds to
one row in the self-similarity matrix
which corresponds to one frame and from
now on so from now on I want to say what
I said before from now on it's all just
this one block they are independent of
each other
okay so you take this one block and you
feed it through a transformer to achieve
at your final embedding of 512 and it's
probably best if we read what they say
about it okay so if we're given this
self similarity matrices matrix they it
consists of row each row is the per
frame self similarity representation and
generates two outputs the per frame
period length estimation and the per
frame binary periodicity classification
note that both L and P are vectors and
their elements are per frame predictions
okay the architecture of the period
predictor module can be
you didn't figure to note that the
predictors share a common architecture
and waits until the last classification
of phase the shared processing pipeline
starts with starts with 32 2d
convolutional filters of size three by
three followed by a transformer layer
which uses a multi-headed attention with
trainable positional embeddings in the
form of a 64 length variable that is
learned by training okay it's I guess
the transformer is learned by training
and the positional embeddings are also
learned by training that's fairly common
we use four heads with 512 dimension in
the transformer by the way if you don't
know what a transformer is watch the
video on attention is all you need I
made one it's very popular yeah
so with each head being 128 dimensions
in size after the shared pipeline we
have two classifiers period length
classifier and periodicity classifier
tau sorry this is fine this is tau each
of them consists of two fully connected
layers of size 512 so I guess the the
the pipe on here is pretty simple the
question could be why do they use a
transformer and not simply another
convolutional network so here they up
sample the image as we saw in 232
channels and then they simply want to
take one of these one of these blocks
here and that corresponds a little bit
so we have for one frame right what does
it mean we have basically we have 64 by
32 things so the sixty-four things it's
this one frames temporal connection to
each other frame given that you know
comes from this self similarity matrix
so it kind of relates this frame that
we're considering to each of the other
frames and each of this each of these
entries is a 32 size vector this is sort
of a this is you can consider it like a
sequence of 64 things 64 embeddings
so to use a transformer here it's pretty
natural if you think of this as like a
sequence transformation task I would
guess so the transformer can if there
are these Peaks right here like we saw
right here the transformer can make very
good sense of that because of course the
attention mechanism from a1 peak it can
attend to all the other peaks and can
sort of relate the different Peaks to
each other and then determine the
periodicity length whereas with a
convolutional Network
I guess that's going to be a lot harder
because of the sort of invariance built
into the convolution I'm not sure maybe
they also it just worked better but
that's how I think about it it's that
for a given frame you basically have a
sequence classification or a set
classification task and the attention
mechanism allows you to in one single
step connect each peak with each other
peak or each information with each other
information in this sequence alright so
at the end you have just fully connected
layers again only on a per frame basis
and that will give you the output and
again you compare this to the label and
you back prop through everything
everything here is differentiable so all
of this is trained to achieve minimum
possible loss and because you train
everything to achieve minimal possible
loss you make this encoder right here
which is the crucial part because the
encoder is must give you good embeddings
which must give you a sensible
self-similarity matrix right you train
the encoder to encode things that are
relevant for the task and that's what
makes the whole thing work okay so we've
gone through the architecture now the
problem right here is the the data set
so they also go into how they do
inference they can actually do a bunch
things like play the video at different
speeds and then look at with each of the
predictions so if at double speed it
predicts half the period length then you
can be more sure and so on so that's
pretty cool but they go into another
point right here and that's the data set
so they produce this count ticks data
set but also on the other hand which is
something I also find very cool is they
produce a synthetic data set so here
they say we train with synthetic
repetitions and that can be sort of I
didn't know what to think of it at first
I was just like huh but then it's pretty
cool so if you have a video with these
these are the frames of the video right
so the video goes in this temporal
direction what you can do is simply go
here go through these frames and just
repeat these frames and repeat them and
repeat them and at the end do you have
these frames right and then you have a
data set and if you if you assume that
most videos do not naturally contain
repeating actions right most videos are
just videos there are not videos of
something repeating then you can safely
assume that these parts here are non
repeating so and these parts here are
repeating this is one of the labels that
you need the problem with synthetic data
set is always to have the labels and
also you know how many there are because
you can simply count the number of times
that you go through it you can even make
it faster slower and so on so this
synthetic approach is pretty cool and
especially the bottom right here because
this might be kind of hacky because each
time each time you jump from the end of
one of those arrows to the beginning
right you have kind of a hack in the
indie video because you know it's not
continuous so what you can do and this
is the the bottom here you can do this
reversal technique where you go to the
end and then you play the frames
backwards and then you play the frames
forwards again backwards again forwards
again and then you go out here
and that gives you one continuous motion
right if someone if it's simply a video
of someone lifting their hand like it
starts out down here and it goes here
and it goes here and then if you do this
technique it would go down again down
again up again up again and so on so
that's you know I think it's a fairly
smart technique honestly now they try
this and it doesn't work super well so
what they also have to do is they have
to do manual camera motion augmentation
so that's so camera motion augmentation
it basically means that if you just do a
repeating action like this it's sort of
I guess it's to monotonic it doesn't
really cover real videos with repeating
actions so what they do is they kind of
simulate a moving camera and you
simulate that much like you would do
image augmentation so you can rotate the
camera over time you can translate it
you can scale it differently and through
if you do that throughout the video and
you change it around how the camera
moves then that appears to work fairly
well so if they now compare this and
their data set they perform pretty well
so in their data set they take this
kinetics data set and they crowdsource
the label and the tasks in the data set
they're pretty diverse as you can see
right here so you have sports like rope
training mountain climber see but you
have also things like playing ukulele
exercising arms slicing an onion and so
on and you can see that the repetition
count is fairly diverse as well so from
one or two repetitions per video goes to
50 or so and the period length is also
between one and five seconds though as
you as I already said you don't have to
you don't have to count on that because
you can always play the video slower or
faster and then determine other
periodicity so in their experiment first
of all they
perform pretty well and they show that
if they train on their dataset and on
the synthetic data set they perform
better than if they just train on the
synthetic or they just train on their
data set they also show pretty clearly
that the addition of this temporal self
similarity matrix helps tremendously you
can see right here in each of these
boxes is the comparison and this OBO I
think is the off by one error so it kind
of forgives you if you're off by one
count but otherwise you get a zero if
you're wrong and you can see that the
self similarity matrix helps
tremendously they also compare with some
other architectural choices instead of
the transformer I guess yeah so I guess
they just take it because it performs
pretty well and they do a lot of lot of
ablations but what I particularly
appreciate is that they do something
like this so what they do at the end
when once they've trained the
architectures they do a 1d PCA
projection of the encoder features over
time now the encoder features they were
512 dimensional right this is the thing
before it goes into the self-similarity
matrix so those we said the encoder is
the crucial part here because it needs
to take the video and encode things that
make them accessible to calculating the
self similarity now they do a 1d PCA so
a projection into one dimension of these
features and you can already see at this
one dimensional projection that the
periodicity here is clearly clearly
visible namely for example right here
every time up here is when the legs are
up and every time down here is when the
legs are down right here so that is very
very impressive and that kind of that
really shows that the model is doing
what you claim what you claim that it's
doing like I'm almost more interested in
experiments like
and in these numbers right here because
the numbers could always be because
you've just thrown more stuff at it
right so they go over a bunch of
possible applications of their model so
first of all you can do something like
as we can see repetition counting from
videos you can do periodicity detection
those were the things that the model is
trained to do but there is also a bunch
of things that the model can now
implicitly do namely something like
change inspection where they say look if
someone's chopping this pineapple right
here then at the end of each of the
repetitions there is you know something
that changed namely the number of slices
of pineapple is it bread is it I can't I
think it's pineapple okay so the number
of slices or pieces right here changes
so in essence this could be the base for
another model estimating whatever
changed or training to recognize numbers
of pieces and so on also you can detect
the speed so the speed of a repeating
action if you perform something slow or
fast this model can implicitly do it and
this they call cross period retrieval so
if you know when the repetitions are you
know that okay maybe the first frame so
always on the upswing right here this
should all this should all be fairly
similar visually right as with respect
to the repeating action so you can see
that even though this whenever the kid
in the swing here is close it looks
fairly different in in a purely visual
sense in a pixel sense but it is at the
same point in the repeating action and
that's you know that's that's pretty
cool so you can technically retrieve
related things even though they visually
they don't look similar that much yeah
that that's the the kind of applications
here are probably many many fold and I
also think that
so in this measure of intelligence paper
by Francois Shirley
he basically claims that this is one of
the innate abilities of humans they can
count you know they can count things
this is something you're basically born
with and maybe this thing right here
will become sort of a staple staple
component for many other things that we
build AI on I would not be surprised but
maybe it will just fade into history I
think it's a pretty cool project
especially you know the the
architectural choice here to pull
everything through this self-similarity
matrix and they you know just just
looking at this matrix already makes you
kind of know that this thing works
all right this was it from me let me
know in the comments what you think
about the paper check out the website
the website has a lot of video demo
examples of what they're doing I think
the data set as well and yeah I'll see
you next time bye bye